you're not feeling well chicken soup can
help you feel a lot better and here to
make her cure-all chicken soup please
welcome Abby sharp you gotta make it
ahead of time before flu season and you
know feeling so true and this recipe
actually you can make a head you can
actually make everything a head and then
freeze the bet so we'll talk a little
bit okay now tell me what is it about
chicken soup that just really it really
makes you feel better
it's a warmth what else well there's a
lot of things you know first of all when
you think about it chicken soup is
mainly just water right it's mainly
basically basically water and when
you're sick you're dehydrated you're
vomiting you've got diarrhea
you got a fever you you're sneezing you
need to refuel those fluids hmm and you
know it's not just as easy as drinking
water but that hot bowl of soup the
steam that has actually been shown to
kind of loosen up or you know thin out
any clogged up mucus oh you can cough it
up right and that makes you feel better
it's not pretty
we're gonna the food in a minute but
these are the things that happen to all
those hopefully you don't cough it up in
the soup right no but your soup looks so
good
absolutely soothing yeah like above all
else is just a comfort food where do we
begin
well we're gonna start on the chicken
stock here and you know you can make
your own stock I always recommend people
make a stock when they're you know
roasting a chicken but if you're feeling
sick or you're caring for someone sick
no one's expecting you to bust out Julia
Child move here just do it yeah just buy
the boxed reduced chicken stock because
we're gonna doctor it up with lots of
cool that reduce sodium right I always
buy the reduced sodium that way you can
decide how right the salt you want to
add to I gotcha yeah so I've got my
stock up to a nice simmer here adding in
some sliced ginger and garlic both
really great spaces of antioxidants
we got antiviral antibacterial
anti-inflammatory properties going on
gotcha I'm really great here I'm gonna
do a little bit of lemon rind and some
lemon juice that's our vitamin C okay
mom is always right about the vitamin C
right yeah so you put the rind in there
too Wow well just add that flea but we
have Apple lemony flavor okay and then
I'm going in with my my chicken breast
here we're gonna poach up the chicken so
that gives us our protein a little bit
of zinc
Zink is a really important nutrient for
for immunity so that's what we're going
with a little bit of pepper here and you
know if you want to add touch more salt
just be just be gentle with it and I
bring this up to a boil let it you know
reduce it down to simmer pop the lid on
let it go for about 15 minutes and then
I take it off the heat take it off the
burner okay let it sit for another 30
minutes so the chicken cooks through and
all those the nice the lemon the ginger
the garlic it can really infuse into
that broth okay so once again you take
it up to a boil yep then an instant
breeze every 15 minutes 15 minutes let
it sit for another 30 okay got it so now
before we go anywhere you let this cool
down I've shredded up my chicken so you
know it's cooled down for sure up the
chicken got rid of the lemon and the
rind and the ginger and garlic great no
one wants to bite into a big piece of
garlic no in their soup so now we
actually get to make the soup and I
don't has a different take on chicken
soup right I do mine with matzo balls so
we call it Jewish penicillin in my in my
circles and but you don't need to be
Jewish to appreciate this soup I'm
telling you they're gonna make everyone
feel better all right and you know some
people do noodles with their matzo balls
I don't bother I just figure you already
got the carbs from the matzo ball right
right I'd rather have lots more veggies
going in so that's what we're gonna do
now I've got my stock here up to a
simmer adding in carrots a little bit of
sweet potatoes great source of vitamin A
really important for your immunity a
little bit of diced celery here some
onion onion is really really great
source of antibacterial antiviral
flavonoid compounds what about this
celery just because it's color well I
like the celery
I like all right I think Christian okay
well these would say it's tradition
right okay so there we go I'm gonna go
in with the with the matzo ball Turner
and they look small I know but they are
gonna plump up I'm telling you about I'm
they're gonna just know what it's let's
talk about month so what are what is it
matzo balls are basically just a
combination of matzo meal which are the
crushed up
crackers the matzo crackers that you
know the Jewish people eat during
Passover and I use a whole grain you can
we can have the recipe on Maryland CA so
they put in that good just basically a
little water
traditionally its schmaltz which is
rendered chicken fat but I make my
little heart healthier with some canola
oil so it's really cold some eggs in
there super simple and the funny thing
about matzo balls everyone has their own
opinion about what constitutes a good
matzo ball right there another opinion
it's all you know the two parties are
floaters or sinkers I don't have you
heard about this no oh my goodness
it was a big debate bloaters or sinkers
and you know it's like the Montagues are
the Capulets these people do not mix
floors are sinkers you know there's no
crosses so so let me ask you this so
does your family agree with how you make
lots of well well they have no choice
yeah you know if I know the no mods
right right because there's tradition a
tradition that modern edge to it very
nearly so pop these guys in I make
floaters by the way a little bit lighter
okay so puppies in bring let this simmer
for about 15 minutes with the lid on
yeah and don't be tempted to peek
because you got to really let the Ithaca
yeah off do its job it will expand
absolutely so that's what you get here
just gonna turn this down just a touch
because it's getting intense so there
you go so the matzo balls are gonna
plump up they're really cool that's like
right now see they're like at least
twice the size that's great and then in
the last few minutes we're gonna add
everyone's favorite superfood what is it
is that kale or spinach it's kale kale
tons of antioxidants E&T inflammatory
properties tell me you know I don't like
it cuz it'll soften up in the hall wall
exactly that's the point not rolling
your mouth just shreds when you're
eating a salad get rid of the ribs the
ribs are too too too tough bridges take
the lead just take the loop it gotcha
throw in your chicken there that's all
you got to do okay
really really nice hearty serve it up
with a little bit of a little minced
parsley for color cuz you eat with your
eyes first and some love and some love
sort of little love Tim look I made for
you honey I hope you feel better I'm
leaving now and they take your mask and
your dog make that back out of the room
because you know that I get sick right
okay to help you make your own delicious
soup everyone is gonna go home with a
teeth out clip so pressure cooker worth
$200
Marilyn